- How are you?
- I'm awesome.
Awesome.
- Okay, I've been very much
looking forward to this
'cause your wife was just
here, Pink if you don't know,
then you're living under a rock.
But anyway, so when she was here,
we were talking about
lyrics and like melodies
of everything like, you know, musically,
she's coming out on the album
and she wrote a number of songs about you
and had this to say when
we asked her how you felt
about those songs.
So I just wanna play this for you.
- Well, you have to take in
like Carey's amount of feelings
he can handle and how much he is actually
thinking about the words that I'm saying
or listening at all.
- Oh, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- So I think--
- That's fun.
- I think he's fun.
There's one on the new album
that's, that was a hard day,
and I played it for him
because that's fair,
he should know what's being
said about him in the world.
And he just started
giggling and he is like,
"Well, you're welcome."
And I'm like...
- All right.
- Is that all accurate?
- Yeah, it's very accurate.
You know, we've been together 21 years.
I have very thick skin.
- [Kelly] That's so cool, 21 years.
- Very little affects me and you know,
I don't know exactly what day
she's talking about specifically
but it's probably just
the temperature, yeah.
- It's like I love that so much.
I love you two as a couple.